اريد ان اركز معك على ما شاهدنا الان في
الخريطه على اهم النقاط شمالا حتى في هذه
اللحظات هناك اشتباكات قويه في محور
جباليه تل الزعتر كذلك في حي الشجاعيه
جنوبا خان يونس الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول
بانه تقدم في بعض المحاور ثم تاتي بيانات
المقاومه وكذلك شهود اليام وتنفي كما
تابعنا قبل قليل في مخيم جبالي وهذا ما
نقله لنا مراسل الجزيره قبل قليل وبالتالي
كيف نفهم هذا الاصرار هذا التكثيف الحديث
عن حدوث تقدم والتركيز ايضا لغايه هذا
اليوم على هذه
المناطق عبد القادر يعني المؤشرات
الميدانيه
والتكتيكيه هي ستحدد صوره المرحله القادمه
الاسرائيلي لديه عدوين اليوم لديه حماس
ولديه الوقت والكل يتحدث عن المسار
للتفاوض لتبادل الرهائن والوقفه الانسانيه
والخلاف هل سيكون هو وقف للنار مستمر
ودائم الصوره التكتيكيه هي التي ستحدد
المرحله القادمه من هنا يسعى الجيش
الاسرائيلي الى الانتهاء بالحد الادنى كما
يقال كلير يعني تنظيف منطقه الشمال خاصه
جباليا وهو تحدث البارحه انه انهى جباليا
بالمعنى العسكري ويتجه الى الشجاعيه والى
المحيط من هذه المناطق يسعى ال الى الى
كما يقال بال
يعني اللغه العسكريه التنظيف وليس
بالضروره ان يبقى فيها لانه قد يتركها عبد
القادر للمرحله القادمه او الفيز 3 التي
تحدث عنها لويد اوستن يعني التطويق
وبالتالي تسليم اليه معينه امنيه في
الداخل والانتقال الى مرحله الاستعلام
التكت وما شبه والقيام بعمليات اغاره على
قيادات او مقاتلين من حماس هذا بال بالعقل
الاسرائيلي اثنين في الوسط هو يريد فعلا
عزل الوسط عن الشمال وعن الجنوب ومن هنا
بدانا نرى حركيه جديده في وسط القطاع وهي
التي كانت متروكه لفتره طويله اما في
منطقه الجنوب وهنا يلعب الوقت ضد العدو
الاسرائيلي محاوله تطويق خان يونس وليس
بالضروره ان يدخل اليها عبد القادر يعني
ان يدخل اليها يجب ان نقارنه الى حد ما مع
ما جرى في شمال القطاع يعني شمال القطاع
ثلاثه اشهر تقريبا ولا نزال في الشجاعيه
ولا نزال في جباليا فهذا الامر لا يسمح له
الوقت بهذا الموضوع يريد
فرض واقع معين وبعدها الانتقال الى
المرحله الثالثه التي تحدث عنها لويد
اوستن ولكن هناك الكثير من التناقضات عبد
القادر اذا اردت سنوسع هذا الموضوع في
الروايه الاسرائيليه العميد الياس تناقضات
نعم بالتناقض يعني التناقض او البارادوكس
كما يقال او المفارقه يعني انت تريد ان
تذهب الى وقف للنار وتريد ان تسلمك حماس
اليه معينه لتسليم الرهائن او الاسرى
اسبوعين مقابل 40 هي الريشو يعني المعدل
ولكن انت تقول لحماس انا سلميني هؤلاء
الرهائن كي ارتاح سياسيا وارتاح عسكريا
ولكن سوف اسعى لتدمير حماس وحتى تهديد
وزير الخارجيه وزير الماليه بملاحقه
قيادات حماس يعني انت تقول لي اعطني ما
لديك او القوه التي بين يديك وهي الرهائن
والاسرى ولكن في النهايه سوف اقتلك وهذا
امر يقلق حماس يقلق حماس وبالتالي لن
تستسلم وسوف تبقى تذهب الى القتال من هنا
مطالبه حماس بوقف نار مستمر ودائم اعود
معك الى ما تم بثه هذا اليوم من قبل الجيش
الاسرائيلي بالحديث انه اجرى عمليه مسح
لكافه الانفاق في شمال قطاع غزه وانه وضع
يده على بعض مراكز التحكم لقاده حماس هل
باللغه عسكريه بلغه المتابعه للتطورات
العسكريه ما الهدف من قول هذا الكلام سواء
كان صادقا او فيه كثير من
التضليل هل هو تحقيق انجاز عبقادر هو
الهاجس ه هو الهاجس للانفاق نحن يعني نقول
ان حماس تستعمل الفاق والمناطق السكنيه
هذه عبد القادر هي نقطه المقاومه يعني
المقاومه ليست خارج عن البيئه التي تعيش
فيها فلنم حماس في صحراء تقاتل اهم جيش في
العالم ماذا كانت لتقوم ضد افضل جيش
بالعالم متقدم تكنولوجيا وعسكريا فاذا هذه
نقطه النقطه الاساس وهي العامل المقلق
وتبين بعد المرحله الاولى من الحرب انه ال
العمى الاستخباراتي في مخص الانفاق فكيف
ان ان ان ان يجد نفق يصل الى معبر ارتس
بطول 4 كل يمكن استعماله لاليات معينه
وبالتالي يمكن يمكن ان تسير فيه سيارات
اساسيه خاصه بعد ان يعتبر نفسه انه سيطر
على شمال قطاع غزه يعتبر هذا النصر وكلما
تقدم سيقول انه هناك نصر مهم ولكن الشيء
المهم عبد القادر وهنا بيت القصيد يقول
انه دمر كتيبه جباليا دمر كتيبه الشجاعيه
اليوم تدمير كتيبه بالمعنى العسكري
التقليدي شيء وبمعنى كما تقاتل شي حماس
شيء اخر يعني يكفي ان يبقى من الكتيبه 10
او 15% من كتائب القسام كي تكون قادره على
انزال الخسائر يعني يكفي الار بي جي او
التي بيجي او الياسين 105 لانه عامل
المفاجاه دائما هو لصالح المقاومه من
بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي شكرا جزيلا لك